[Musik]
tapetenwechsel nachdem corona wochen
auch für matze und david sie fahren zum
klettern ganz in den osten der republik
in die sächsische schweiz
was mich am anfang auch sehr fasziniert
dass das es ja eines der einzigen oder
wenigen nationalparkgebiet in
deutschland ist und ist es auch wie
generell der osten von deutschland hat
weniger dicht besiedelt so wissen
ursprünglicher und bilder
ankunft im oberen elbtal es geht nach
schmilka das letzte dörfchen vor der
tschechischen grenze gerade mal 73
menschen leben hier noch die meisten
sind rentner
hier wollen matze und david mit ihrem
freund norman die aus dieser gegend
kommt den urlaub verbringen wie schon
seit 122 jahren bringt die
kirnitzschtalbahn die kletterer an ihre
fersen
endlich wieder nach dem wochenlangen
lockdown sind die jungs ganz schön aus
dem training
im wald zeigt sich dann dass corona hier
das kleinste problem ist
[Applaus]
ihr seht ihr was die trockenheit in
kombination mit oben geben soll die
letzten beiden jahre eingerichtet hat
mehr als 30 jahre hier kaputt gegangen
gefangenen darin sächsischen ist richtig
viel kaputt also vielleicht ist das
jetzt einfach so eine chance für das
ökosystem auf natürlichem weg wieder
zurück zu seinen ursprünglichen zustand
zu kommen 1000 hektar fichten sind hier
tod für den wirtschaftswald ist es eine
katastrophe für den nationalpark jedoch
eine chance für gesünderen wald mit mehr
vielfalt in 300 jahren nicht trainiert
haben oder nur an kletterwänden
trainiert haben das ist schon eine ganz
andere nummer
ein bisschen war mir kriegt man schon
die höhe auch die spielt anhalt der
psyche immer ein paar ängste rein und
ich bin halt technisch draußen einfach
nicht so erfahren aber das wird das wird
häufig
[Gelächter]
kaum zu glauben dass man auf diese
spitze in 70 metern höhe
überhaupt stehen kann also gegessen
irgendwie von links irgendwie an dem
dach hoch und quer stan da oben rechts
in den in den rechten kamin wieder rein
die letzten tipps danach ist jeder auf
sich allein gestellt norman ist in ost
weg zur weltspitze noch nie hoch
geklettert
[Musik]
um den weichen sandstein zu schonen
schlagen sie keine metallhaken im
internet gesichert wird mit seil
schwingen
[Musik]
vorstand normen trägt das größte risiko
immer bis zum nächsten sicherungs punkt
klettert ihr völlig frei
[Musik]
auch david schafft es bis zum letzten
halt vor der freistehenden felsspitze
und weil ich dann
ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig an
die strecke nicht mehr einfach zu hoch
geworden sieht auch hier wird man händen
und armen
und jetzt bin ich hier doch einer fehlt
noch
auch matze erreicht nun die letzte
zwischenstation
[Musik]
es fehlen nur noch zehn meter bis zur
felsen spitze auf andere felsen kommt
man leichter hoch im zweifel sogar mit
dem auto der bastei felsen ist der
touristenmagnet der sächsischen schweiz
die pandemie hier und heute anscheinend
vergessen
[Musik]
schon vor 200 jahren stand hier eine
würstchenbude für ausflügler die den
blick ins elbtal genießen wollten
[Musik]
in diesem sommer wird der boom zum immer
größeren problem sagt nationalpark
manager hans peter maier
obwohl wäre das dichteste wegenetz in
einem deutschen nationalpark haben über
500 kilometer wanderwege und 100
aussichten
das ist einfach diesen ansturm nicht
mehr gewachsen es wird geraucht im wald
wir hatten schon leider die ersten
beiden waldbrände die von besuchern
verursacht wurden aber klar verstehen
wir das auch dass nach dieser langen
zeit menschen aus wald und es gibt sie
natürlich auch hier die unberührten
flecken das legendäre gipfelbuch die
einträge auf manchen fels spitzen hier
gehen bis in die 30er jahre zurück und
jetzt verewigen sich norman matze und
david
das letzte stück ist einfach nur noch
schön und genuss bisher super exponiert
und das 360 grad blick auf alle fälle
sehr geil ich finde doch das ist ein
kleines wunder ist dass ich jetzt hier
sitzen haben wir ja gar nicht mich
umzudrehen
aber es war gut das war gut dass hier ja
mitgeschleift habt hat man sich nicht
vorzeitig aufgegeben habe wir haben und
ja es hat sich gelohnt
[Musik]